Speaker 1: All right, let's keep hearing from
folks in the audience via Discord. You can chat
with me via voice right now at David Pakman dot
com slash discord. We are going to go next to
Markus from Sacramento. Marcus, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Thanks for taking my call,
Dave. Pleasure. So my question is in regards to
Republicans moving forward on the national scale,
it seems as though Republicans are able to
basically push Trump's agenda without the pushback
that Trump would get because Trump was such a
polarizing figure. The first person that comes
to mind is like a Ron DeSantis. So I guess my
overarching question is, can Republicans basically
be Trump lite without without the ramifications
Trump would have? And secondly, who do you
think gets the Republican nomination in 2024?
Speaker 1: Second part, I have no idea. Too much,
too much still to to see. We must have the 2022
results before we can really think seriously
about 2024. But on your first question, the
answer is absolutely yes, and it's dangerous.
I've talked before about how someone like Ron
DeSantis, who has all of the same kind of immoral
or amoral instincts of Donald Trump, a lot of
the radical ideology, but is less cartoonishly
unhinged. He's still unhinged. He just just less
cartoonishly unhinged. He may actually be able
to do a lot of the things Trump merely wanted
to do, but failed to do. So you are absolutely
correct that the Trump agenda, to the extent
that it is an agenda and it's kind of not. But,
but to the extent that it's an agenda, it would
be far more likely to be carried on by people
less cartoonishly problematic. And Ron DeSantis
is a perfect example of such a such an individual.
Speaker 3: Just one last follow up. Do
you think DeSantis has a chance in 2024
Speaker 1: to be the nominee or to become
president? Both. I think, to be the nominee, yes,
although it depends a lot on whether Trump runs
and to become president. Yeah. I mean, listen,
look. Look at the country. That electorate
elected Trump in 2016. So certainly this is
a country that would be ignorant enough to elect
DeSantis president. Yeah, it's very, very scary.
Speaker 3: That's that is scary. Yeah.
Speaker 1: But thank you, David. My pleasure.
Thank you for the call. Very much. Appreciate it.
Let's go next. So many folks chatting here today.
Let's go
Speaker 3: to Cooper
Speaker 1: from Colorado.
Cooper, you're on the air.
Hey, David, can you hear
me? I can hear you fine you.
Speaker 3: Awesome. Huge fan of the show,
I wish I had a question, I always think of
some but never written down, but just want to. I
think it was last week or two weeks ago you had
a mustache. I thought it looked excellent, sir.
Speaker 1: Oh, thank you. Yes, I may. I may do
it again. I was. I was asked to get rid of it
before this wedding I went to over the weekend,
I was told it would be really embarrassing
for everybody involved for me to show up at
the wedding with the mustache. But I'm going
to I'm going to get it going again, I think.
Speaker 3: Awesome. Hopefully no shave November.
Speaker 1: Exactly. All right. Thanks, Cooper.
Very good and there. Cooper has come and gone